Director Matt Reeves' The Batman may not have
Ben Affleck rocking the cape and cowl anymore,
but what it does apparently have are two main
villains plucked straight from the Batman
canon the second of which may have just been
revealed.
A casting breakdown for The Batman, obtained
by We Got This Covered through undisclosed
sources, reportedly details that the secondary
baddie in the film is a character currently
being billed as "The Brain."
There's a villain who goes by that name in
the DC universe: a mad scientist best known
for serving as a member of the Brotherhood
of Evil, joining the Secret Society of Super
Villains, and battling against the band of
crime-fighting misfits known as the Doom Patrol.
It would be an interesting choice for a central
antagonist in a more noir-driven, detective
version of Batman — especially considering
the Brain and Batman aren’t exactly arch-enemies.
Of course, it’s entirely possible that the
Brain isn’t the secondary villain in the
forthcoming film after all, but simply a code
for a different super-villain set to battle
Batman.
“Surf’s up, big Kahuna!”
According to We Got This Covered’s intel,
"the Brain" is actually code for a far more
prominent DC Comics villain: the Riddler.
As avid Batman readers will know, the "Brain"
could here be a reference to the fact that
the Riddler is Batman's most intelligent arch-villain.
Otherwise known as Edward Nigma, The Riddler
possesses genius-level smarts and revels in
crafting dastardly plots that involve complex
riddles, traps, and puzzles.
Showy, over-elaborate, and weirdly passionate
about the crimes he commits, the Riddler has
long existed as one of Batman's greatest and
most notorious adversaries.
"What squeals louder than a caught rat?”
“Answer... several caught rats."
What makes the Riddler’s presence in the
Reeves-helmed flick even more plausible is
that the primary bad guy of The Batman is
reported to be the Penguin., this Gotham City
mobster has a flair for the dramatic and a
penchant for all things avian.
A team-up between the two villains wouldn’t
be too out of the ordinary, either, since
the Penguin has frequently partnered with
the Riddler, both on-screen and off.
While the Fox television series Gotham has
depicted both the Riddler and the Penguin
throughout the show's run, neither villain
has appeared on the big screen since the 1990s.
Tim Burton's Batman Returns featured Danny
DeVito as the Penguin, while Joel Schumacher's
1995 feature Batman Forever saw Jim Carrey
give an over-the-top performance as the Riddler.
“Thank you.”
Some might argue that Carrey and DeVito were
perfect — and maybe even irreplaceable — in
their roles, but it's been over 25 years since
the release of Batman Returns and Batman Forever,
and the Riddler and the Penguin are long overdue
for a silver screen face lift.
Reeves' movie could be the perfect platform
to do just that.
Obviously, it goes without saying that this
is all guesswork for now.
No one directly involved with The Batman has
confirmed that the Riddler will be a part
of the story, and nobody has corroborated
the talk that the Penguin will appear, either.
Nonetheless, this rumor does seem just about
plausible enough to be true — and it can
only help that the Riddler has already found
his roots in the DC Extended Universe, thanks
to a sneaky little Easter egg in Batman v
Superman: Dawn of Justice.
Until someone finally steps up and confirms
The Batman’s lead villains, however, fans
are just going to have to count down the days
until the film releases on June 25th, 2021.
Of course, if that gets too boring, they could
always pass the time by fan-casting the Riddler.
Our money's on DiCaprio.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.